welcome back to CBS this morning time to
bring you some of the stories that are
the talk of the table this morning this
is where we each pick a story we'd like
to share with each other and with all of
you you know how it goes and Gayle King
you're going first
yes oh thanks thanks Anthony
mine is about I like mine too
Barbara Streisand and George Floyd's
little girl if you're going huh what's
the connection there's one George
Floyd's six year old daughter we all met
her when she said my daddy changed the
world when she was riding on top of
someone's shoulders
well anyway little Gianna received a
surprise gift the other day that could
pay huge dividends on Instagram Gianna
Floyd thanks Barbra Streisand for a
package she writes I am now a Disney
stock holder thanks to you
Streisand also sent gianna copies of two
of her albums now it's not clear how
many shares it Streisand bought for
little Gianna but we certainly do
appreciate the gesture I do know Anthony
and Tony the albums that she sent were
my name is Barbara and Color Me Barbara
you haven't lived till you've heard
Barbara's sing my man now something
tells me Gianna is not a Barbra
Streisand fan yet but there's nobody
that sounds like Barbra Streisand so we
say bravo to her and my hope is if
Gianna hasn't been to Disneyland that
she gets to go one of these days Anthony
I hope so - yeah so - Gail and I love
both of those albums I will say I
remember my grandmother was a stock for
a birthday it was Eastman Kodak stock it
didn't turn out so well so you know
those gifts can go both ways gonna do
okay